you've directed a Tom Hanks once again
you've directed it many times to the
fifth time fifth time an inferno you
guys are really good friends good
buddies he's such a nice guy
and then he just did an impression of
you on Saturday Night Live days ago and
I'm curious did he ask permission first
or do you just go for it let's take a
look I want to get your reaction you
tell me if this is accurate your host
Ron Howard
[Music]
hit bloopers just make me giggle I can
use a good laugh after working all day
well I can look down there a long time
I'd pull it up in the air okay
[Applause]
he warned me he warned me and this is an
impression that he occasionally does so
I know but you know he's a great guy
he's unbelievably it's very nice very
yummy yummy talented yeah would you say
he's an impressionist I mean do you
think that's any kind of real pressure I
don't think you do this thank you you
just did it and you do it a lot
backstage maybe he's mad at you maybe
he's mad at you because when you see
Inferno there's incredible I mean you
put Tom Hanks through his paces on
Inferno you put him and there are scenes
where I can tell this is not a body
double
oh no you actually at one point you have
him in amazing scenes but underwater it
looks like there's no other way for it
to be anyone else well he looked going
back to splash he's good under the water
he's very game resumes yeah and he's you
know look he's unbelievably cool but we
did that we shot that on in fact on the
on the last day of shooting and we were
we were dragging him under there and you
can he banging his head against this
pillar and it's a very you know there's
a lot of a lot of excitement and action
in the climax of the movie and he did
pop up and he said Ron Howard
professional director saves the stuff
that can kill the star to the last day
and no he lived through it yeah does he
have a point you do that on purpose
I love having Ron Howard on but the
danger is he's so foul-mouthed oh he's
just notorious in the business you're
just an animal
you